hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the amnesia of full
conversion my
now this is actually one that I probably
should have played a long time ago
because it's very very interesting and
very very converted anyway
yeah it takes the story takes place
basically after after the end of amnesia
- when you go through the port hence the
name true - portal it's probably too
loud right now sorry now you can hear me
better that's better sorry about that
alright I'm ready if you already know I
guess it must have been made after
Justine was released either way here we
go yes
I'm actually kind of excited about this
one because you know I've passed it over
quite a few times back when I was early
doing most recently I did
really
tried to find good
and in interesting
[Music]
it will be alright it won't be alright
Wow that is cool
that is like crazy cool it reminds me of
Oh Ariel it reminds me of the scene
after half-life 2 the first main game
and then the start of episode 1 when
you're staring up at the tower that's
what it really reminds me of you know
the sky is kind of blown out the band
this is cool
holy hell there's the shattered orb I
suppose that was used to send me over
here Wow
I mean wow look at this this is
incredible fight known about this sooner
I would have definitely give it a try
wow man I didn't even know that amnesia
engine could do stuff like this I'm like
flabbergasted at the amount of work
that's put into this area that's crazy
like seriously that looks just like the
beginning of episode one and halfway
very very cool getting stuck a little
brush it's got a lantern now I've got
full oil
hello hello
Aki ancient key not just a key this key
looks as if it has existed since the
dawn of time
now that's an ancient key No where do we
put this angel Alexander's ruins
Wow I don't know if you guys can see his
picture right now but this loading
screen is very cool I can tell that a
lot of work went into this mod I'm
pretty excited actually I haven't had a
good full conversion modern one Wow
still cool
I mean obvi onsen atmosphere now it
kinda reminds me of Dhoom 3 and the S I
have played doom 3 before I know people
have suggested that's for me to play
amazing I'm like I'm like it'd be
enthralled by the environment right now
whoa what the hell holiday hellos that's
kind of creepy okay
I didn't notice that Oh get over was
there anything over here
besides this picture of Justine Oh
[Music]
what the hell was that oh my that was
something strange okay dead bodies over
there some strange orb here otherworldly
device activated hello baby oh hi there
you look a little trapped in that wall
I'll get you take an air of your
skateboard Nevermore Vargas yeah how
robert duvall Ramon okey-dokey
okay man that's cool we will be reunited
Justine ah I miss you more than words
can describe
my love I am doing terrible things for
you what's worse is I am not certain the
acquisition of this video will even
bring you back I'm leaving the day for
towards 4:00 in search of more shame on
my selfishness and my deep sorrow for
the next puppet I use still I would
destroy the lives of a hundred more if
that is what it takes
Alexander oh okay there was another
custom story that kind of played on the
whole Alexander in the portal wolf not
with just either
oh hello hello hi how are you doing - go
but the bones Oh nuts ass-backwards
Wow get out of there nothing a whole lot
of nothing what are you hiding back here
nothing more nothing
how much nothing can there be oh there's
so much nothing
oh wait without power
wicked crazy kooky let's see this
indescribable object in stills alien
knowledge into your mind allowing you to
read and interpret a strange language
this looks like a smaller version of the
orbs that scar your history appears to
power alien devices okay so I need to
power alien devices simple the strange
device seems wired of nearby door maybe
if I put them how go on it yep
whatever you did seemed to unlock the
door I don't think there's anything else
in your right nope
moving forward man this is so cool man
I'm like totally I'm totally digging
this Joe ah what the hell was that
holy huh no jumping jack flash
does it sound I've never heard before
and when they said total conversion my
identity they meant it in this one holy
crap let's see find a way back home free
of your past did I write that what is
something like that
offices
comparisons of realm foreign inertia
caring strangely though unlike the last
sample the beings of a realm for appear
to have be unable to comprehend some of
our basic wildlife one of the travelers
whereas it was called was completely
oblivious to a wild Karen the aquatic
cousin of the La Rue
he explained there was simply no visual
to go along with the effects of Carrick
had on its environment possibly the
tempter renders them invisible despite
the pain I caused orb travel yields such
interesting data and will be frequenting
realm for I'm guessing realm for is
earth well done mark your thoughts
marked wow I bet no one else picked up
on that either way now our invisible
wall this reminds me of doom now again
like hellscape there's a tower but it's
different where the other towers this is
so cool I can't I can't get over how
cool this is like I don't know why this
well maybe it'll appear later but I
don't know why this mod was rated it's
only an eight point eight I would give
this like a ten out of ten on the
environment alone just like solar engine
oh that's a Carrick beware
infested
I guess I can't even go in there it's an
invisible wall now where are we go what
is this some sort of portal device okay
I don't think there's anything else here
I saw another warp that I can power over
yonder way I get the feeling that
Alexander is not dead yeah strangely the
great underground well now let's see
what's inside the great underground
I always appreciate excellent and
intricate use of limited resources and
just like the things in the night this
one is there we are
holy Wow
I can't tell but it says go that way but
it's obviously blocked off huh all right
only one way to go then Wow
oh that's bad oh that's probably bad ah
okay I like oh I think something's
chasing hard to tell haha okay Wow good
open thank you
how was that is that the darkness
another form of the darkness they did
say that the darkness originated from
this world didn't they
Wow
holy crap oh man this something else
there's ways there's a platform up there
so hard to see nope okay I don't do that
quite yet say orbit riding to the left
this door lacks any type of handle
switcher power cord plug rm3 Ralph ah I
see surround for that way
whoa
this is an org it looks as if a portal
in the great underground points to earth
however seems a morgue is needed to
power the portal much like Alexander's
what about this orb I have right here
no okay wow that's so cool it's so cool
this made this custom stories awesome
like no Chuck
all right so I need to find what the
hell this door just burst off its
engines whoo
what what the hell
Wow oh my
this exploring
Wow what is that like Citadel or city or
something
hauling crap all la I know I've been
saying that a lot but meaning this
spire of Lights it's not that secret
actually
it doesn't look like there's anything
else out yourself let's go in the spire
of lights see what happens yeah
obviously I just need to find an orbit
and get back to earth I'm wondering if
this is actually gonna take that long I
don't know how long the portal is I
don't know how long any of these custom
stories are I just blow them up hope for
the best because I don't look up any
gameplay videos or anything like that
hello spot music shifted well that's
weird
I won't count that against him looks
like some weird infestation starting up
here ah
this looks more familiar ah and then no
red nail our study number six an
interesting side effect of
experimentation today it seems the big
beings of realm four secrete what is
known what we know is vit a the basic
matter of our organic life to find such
a domestic substance so far from home is
simply mind-boggling yet it is
reassuring in the sense we are all
indeed part of the same universe however
I fear from this Discovery's progress as
the methods required to extract vid
excrete vit a from realm fors
inhabitants is troubling to say the
least
all right well I'm actually gonna pause
here because I am all out of time but
this is incredibly interesting mod I am
very very very very looking forward to
playing this so thank you all so much
for watching and as always we'll see you
in the next part bye-bye